going back to the recording in an atom
i'll turn it over to you if you got any
questions going back to the recording
that you had right because i think the
call was
rahm emanuel said here's four names pick
one of them this is who obama wants what
do you want and i think at the top of
the list was what jesse jackson jr
because when a sitting senator goes and
becomes a president the current governor
is able to appoint somebody in that seat
and a lot of times that's a leverage
point right historically it's not the
first you're not the first person i went
through this this happens regularly and
there's some kind of leverage and
negotiation sometimes it's political
sometimes it's campaign support
sometimes it's an endorsement sometimes
it's a lot of different things that you
read about but the the recording goes i
got this thing and it's uh golden right
and i'm not giving it up for nothing i'm
not gonna do it there's a life after
that if i do it right you guys are
telling me to sit here for two years as
a governor and do nothing everyone is
passing me by give it up for nothing and
then uh you know he says who's passing
you by and doing you know who's doing
this and you said everybody right he
wanted jesse jackson and at the end he
said only 13 percent of you think i'm
doing a good job
uh and then rahm says you know i want
jesse anyways the problem is how do we
take some of my financial pressure off
of me that was the one statement that
you made how do we take somebody to find
out and what's funny is even though they
have that in recording out of the 24
counts
they didn't hold you right you didn't
you know you were not found guilty for
that statement right so it was for a
completely different account something
that happened in the past donation they
were talking about earlier fundraising
stuff fundraising stuff that happened so
while you're in this moment and going
through this and you hear that the
recording is public and it's michael
casey i think that'll prove it i think
mike michael you casey i don't know
exactly what his name is that's right he
was the assistant attorney general he
was the attorney general he was the one
that approved recording you and
wiretapping you to listen with no
probable cause by the way with no
probable cause which which by the way
this goes back to
some of the things when i talked to rudy
giuliani rudy giuliani said this whole
thing with rico we changed it because
that professor from uh rutgers universe
i don't know what university was that he
said here's how we can get the you know
mob let's just change the laws on rico
and they changed it and we know what
happens with that they were able to get
the mob uh to go away so
while you heard yourself when the
recording came public and you heard it
what was your initial reaction ouch you
kidding me i cringed when i heard
especially the f-word i was flinging it
around by the way rahm emanuel says it
way more than i do he's not on the tapes
all over the place of course you can't
play him but uh and that's no
justification that's not a diamond he
gets him either it's just you know
sometimes we talk locker room
among the guys there were no women on
those calls when i was using that word
but real quick um
that was a career day call in other
words we spent two hours on that call
you couldn't play they wouldn't let us
play
any of that tape other than what they
played that snippet where i'm venting
because the discussion part of the
discussion was do i just not be governor
anymore because
uh
the fbi had gone out and ruined my
wife's real estate business by going to
all of her customers and clients and
everybody was afraid to do any business
with her so we were actually facing some
difficult financial circumstances and
the discussion was do i just no longer
stay as governor or do i stay as
governor for two years or should i make
myself a u.s senator and how does how
would that work for our family
unlikely i would ever do anything like
that but that's brainstorming and you're
supposed to be able to talk freely and
honestly in conversations they're not
crimes unless you actually do something
that's actually criminal none of those
things were you could legally make
yourself a senator i was unlikely to do
it but these were discussions that we
had for two hours on that particular
call
and i was angry too because i knew these
feds were on my ass yeah i knew it and i
and i was fearful that they were going
to do everything they could to get me
because that's such a big investment in
getting me the irony is it's those very
conversations where i'm super careful i
don't do anything wrong that they twist
and take out of context and make these
things sound worse than they are
every
i on average talk to my lawyer three
times a day when during that period of
time we could never introduce that into
evidence because i asked him can i do
this can i do that how to do a deal like
this because everybody was coming to me
with different ideas creative ideas and
what you might want to do with the
senate seat like oprah winfrey we
discussed her for two days and whether i
should appoint her senator she wouldn't
take it but we discussed that
realistically i haven't did something
really stupid you want to hear this
which they played at the first trial
we can swear here right yes all right
and this is stupid and it's childish
i'm on the phone a bunch of guys on the
phone we're talking about i'd like
ideally to appoint a black person to the
united states senate
because obama's the only black person
he's leaving there'll be 99 100 senators
that we don't replace him with someone
who's african-american no black people
united states senate in the age of obama
so i would like one ideally but i don't
want the usual old people in politics
and you know some people
you know they have their own agenda
you know i'm asking my chief of staff to
find me
a black person with a strong military
background somebody like that who's not
known let's keep thinking creatively and
think outside the box so then i do this
stupid thing i say hey quinlan he's my
lawyer hey quinlan what's the law again
about residency to be a a senator how
long do you got to live in illinois he
says you got to live in illinois for one
day you got to be 30 years old and you
it's okay if you're a naturalized
citizen so then i say hey why doesn't
somebody reach out to halle berry in
hollywood ever moved to illinois for one
day i'll make her a senator maybe i
could [ __ ] her
you say this i say this of course i'm
not doing any of this this is just
childish ridiculous locker room talk
with a bunch of guys so there i am at
the first trial okay
and boy that's a bad place to be and
they're playing these tapes okay yeah
and you got this big notebook in front
of you and you can look leaf ahead and
see what they what they're going to play
next what they're going to play next i
don't remember half of this stuff okay
so i'm looking ahead it's about 11 40 in
the morning generally the judge will
break for lunch at noon media's all over
the place every day right my devoted
loving wife there in the front row right
by her husband my wife patty
and uh
i look ahead whoa and i see here comes
that they're gonna play the halle berry
tape it's got no relevance it's just
gonna be designed to prejudice the jury
against me okay
and cause friction with my wife that's
why they're playing this thing i see it
i look at the clock and i say
they've got a few more tapes to play
maybe we can get to noon at least i
might be able to defuse this a little
bit if i get to lunch break before they
play this and warn her that this is
coming after lunch
sure enough we got there okay they
didn't play it yet
i take the book i tap her on the knee i
show her look they're going to play this
after lunch just want you to know i was
joking
she looks up at me and she says what are
you
15
that was all that's what she said that's
hot yeah
nothing wrong with her she's a trooper
by the way she's a trooper she's
unbelievable
yeah yeah no halliburi is beautiful but
of course that was never going to happen
but see when they play that stuff out of
context and that's all that's there
and then they start telling the public
that these things are somehow illegal
you're [ __ ] so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]